I'm attending one of the health
professional schools here at the U and
with the prerequisites of course we're
like anatomy physiology biology and yet
those are all offensive and terrible
yeah that seems to be the case we've
discussed quite a quite a bit about
transgenderism and whatnot even more
than say cardiovascular disease and
we've been having recess yeah I know
right
we've had assignments where I would get
docked up or and not get the points if
you didn't say that you would let's say
even change their gender in the medical
profile to the gender that they say
which i think is just terrible periodic
yeah it's fully idiotic if it says on
your if it says on your profile that you
are a member of the sex to which you do
not belong then you are going to get
profiled medically wrong certainly if
you are having if you are having lower
stomach pain and it says on your chart
that you are a man we're gonna be
looking at indigestion if it says you're
a woman we're gonna be looking at
something else okay this is idiotic yeah
so going out that um I guess you were
starting to discuss it I just wanted to
know what your opinion was on sort of
the implications of this not only like a
culturally significant issue that you've
talked about more invading into more
hardcore science institutions especially
considering your wife's a doctor yeah
she is as you may know yeah so I think
that I think it's egregious I think that
biology is biology it's amazing to me
that people who proclaim that they're
scientists are so willing to overlook
basic biology and proclaim that people
who are fully biologically male can
magically become biologically female
we're not talking about people who are
intersex I always like when people who
debate this issue immediately go to the
margin marginal issues where their
actual is blurring of the lines people
who are intersex or they have some
genetic condition they've Klinefelter
syndrome or something right that's not
what we're talking about here the actual
argument of the transgender civil rights
movement is that people who are fully
male can actually become fully female
that is an obvious nonsense it's
obviously nonsense and again if you are
the the very idea that a doctor is
supposed to sit there and profile you
based on what you wish you were is so
insane and stupid and counterproductive
I mean if you're a transgender person
would you really want the doctor
profiling you based along the lines of
organs you don't have if you're if
you're a biological man do you want to
walk into a doctor and he's and he's
trying to figure out how to fix your
uterus you don't have one
it's ridiculous okay the that you know
that stuff is just beyond the pale but
it does demonstrate the full-scale
insanity that now predominates and again
yeah I've had this argument a thousand
times with folks obviously and the use
of politics above science is obvious in
everything from what you're talking
about - even the rewriting of the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual the
latest edition which is completely a
scientific based on no statistical
evidence and was essentially a political
decision - real able gender dysphoria
from a mental illness or a mental
disorder was really called a mental
disorder - it's not a mental disorder at
all it's just an oppression associated
with it that's a mental disorder well by
that definition schizophrenia isn't a
mental disorder it's only the depression
and suicidality they go along with it
that are a mental disorder you can
literally do that with any mental
disorder so it's it's just it's it's
again for people who proclaim that they
care about science and facts to say this
kind of stuff is a scientific and a
factual